[Music]
hello after the deadliest escalation in
violence since last year's war in gaza a
ceasefire between israel and the
palestinian group islamic jihad has come
into force
44 palestinians including 15 children
have been killed since the fighting
began on friday after israel launched
what it described as preemptive strikes
on gaza
it claimed it was only targeting members
of islamic jihad but palestinian
officials say at least one-third of the
deaths have been civilians
two senior islamic jihad commanders have
been killed in the strikes including the
group's leader in southern gaza halide
mansoor
has retaliated with hundreds of rockets
fired across the border some reaching as
far as jerusalem but israel's army said
97 have been intercepted
all this while food and fuel has been
running out for people living in gaza
most are only getting four to eight
hours of electricity a day with crossing
points into the strip closed since
tuesday
separate has more from gaza
well we can say that
the situation is relatively quiet there
were two launching rockets attempt by
the palestinian factions towards israel
and there uh there have
been no israeli response by on these two
attempts
still we can we could hear the israeli
drones flying over
over our heads but there are no
explosions in the last at least 15 to 20
minutes so yes relatively
in comparison with the
last couple or last three days we can
say that
the cease-fire came to effect according
to islamic jihad
the main point of dispute in the last 24
hours was the egyptian guarantees they
they were seeking uh guarantees from
egypt that it will work i mean egypt on
the release of islamic jihad
senior leader that was arrested in the
west bank
bassam asadi so since they got these
guarantees uh islam accepted the
ceasefire there was another
point which is also moving
the the islamic jihad or the the
palestinian prisoner was on a hunger
strike for
more than a hundred day moving him to
the hospital to receive the medical
treatment so these are the two uh
disputed points that seems at the end
they reached an agreement on that so
after the solving this issue islamic
jihad said that it accepted the egyptian
uh
proposal for the ceasefire
your name is following developments from
west jerusalem
there have been a sporadic reports of
incoming rockets uh into israel the
sirens were activated in the south just
a short time ago warning people to take
shelter but as far as israel is
concerned this operation is over it is
saying that the military said a short
time ago that it used
helicopters fighter jets and armed
drones were among the tools it used to
target islamic jihad
across the gaza strip it has thanked
egypt for its role in mediating the
ceasefire but says if
attacks continue
into israel it will not hesitate to
quote act forcefully and says it will
take whatever measures are necessary to
ensure that the daily lives of israelis
will not be disrupted earlier this
evening the prime minister yair lapid
went to the central military base in tel
aviv to assess the situation he had said
earlier that the objectives of the
so-called operation breaking dawn had
been fulfilled and that there was no
need for the operation to continue what
were these objectives from the israeli
strategic mindset the objective was to
neutralize islamic jihad with most if
not all of the senior leadership being
killed as well as
the feeling that a kind of divide had
been created between islamic jihad and
hamas which governs gaza with hamas
remaining on the sidelines there was a
concern that if this operation was
protracted and the death toll continued
to rise that perhaps hamas might enter
the fray it appears for now that that
has not happened
well she's fine